harrison wagner remembered by his
brother and girlfriend just days after
his untimely death
[Music]
jack and christina wagner's 27 year old
son was found dead in a parking lot on
monday in los angeles and in the wake of
the tragedy his loved ones are paying
tribute on social media harrison's older
brother peter shared a series of photos
from their childhood to instagram the
brothers posing together as kids in
similar outfits
plus some snaps of harrison in his high
school football uniform and practicing
his golf swing the caption a simple
message always with you as for
harrison's on and off girlfriend actress
sophia bowie she's also grieving
and showing her love in a lengthy post
sophia calls her tribute a love letter
to her late beau and says she's so
brokenhearted
seven years on and off round and round
we loved each other for better or for
worse in sickness and in health
sophia apologizes for missing some late
night phone calls from harrison in the
days leading up to his death and writes
that she misses sleeping in his quote
polar bear arms i was never alone in
this world with you you were the balm
that soothed my soul you were my guy i
hope that i was that comfort for you i
will always be your babe i will always
choose to love you in this world and in
any other life
harrison's parents jack and christina
have yet to speak out publicly the
former couple who met while co-starring
on general hospital divorced in 2006
after 13 years of marriage
despite their split harrison seemed to
spend a lot of time with both his mom
and dad last month christina shared
photos from a trip to their family ranch
along with the hashtags peter and
harrison love my sons
all right
[Music]
and in march harrison shared a selfie
with his look-a-like pops the caption
fittingly like father like son
[Music]
[Music]
you